the mets rookie left-hander david
peterson will make his third big league
start in his first at citi field and
here's jesus aguilar two outs nobody on
here's the pitch to aguilar and he pulls
it on the ground and that's a base hit
through the left side and aguilar is
aboard with two down here in the top of
the first inning that'll bring corey
dickerson to the plate vickerson a home
run in rbi this year now the one and two
and dickerson smacks this out into left
field and coming in to scoop it up
quickly is jeff mcneal
and the marlins have runners at first
and second brian anderson's got a chance
here here's the pitch and a ground ball
to the left side it shoots through
that's a base hit it's charged by
hamilton and coming around to score and
the marlins move up on the base path
that throw goes on through to the plate
and the marlins take a one to nothing
lead lead off walk and here's conforto
to in tune atticonforto with wilson
ramos on deck
and conforto drives one to deep right
field that goes brenson for a look and
it's out of here
that'll cure the home run drought
michael conforto with his third of the
year a two-run shot to put the meds in
front two to one
impressive though by conforto this is a
guy that didn't give up a lot of home
runs in the minor leagues
alonso walked his first time scored on
conforto's homer
that's driven deep down the left field
line and that ball is out of here it
just cleared the orange line a 2-1 homer
from pete alonso and the mets down lead
at 4-1
a bullet of a home run by alonso who had
gone 41 at bats without a long ball but
he breaks that streak emphatically with
a home run that got out in an eyelash
and the mets now have a three-run lead
so one out of nobody on here is
francisco civeli who struck out his
first time up
rounded over the bag jd on the backhand
the long throw is right on target he has
got a wing
well ever since being pushed to third
base he has made every play
that's a backhand beautiful there's the
strong arm right on the money
logan forsyth to try to start something
up for the marlins against david
peterson who leads four to one
into deep left center field logan
forsyth has gone deep for the marlins
it's four to two
now congratulations to logan on his
first marlins home run he's been
impressive since the marlins have
acquired him he's putting together
quality at bats and man oh man
he just get up on a fastball
first and third and one out mets up four
to two in the fifth big bat here by jd
and jd flies one out to right not very
deep but rosario able to tag at third
he'll score easily
holding it first is mcneal sacrifice fly
for davis drives in a run to make it
five to two new york nice that back yeah
the marlins have them loaded dante has
one hit in 10 at-bats a big spot this
ball game there's a 1-0
and a ground ball is it gonna get
through it does that'll bring home one
and it might bring home a second here's
the throw it's not in time and monte
harrison comes through with a base hit
and drives home two runs it's a one-run
game runners get set to take off forsyth
at second harrison at first with three
and two two out
three two coming and vr tries to hold he
went around strike three
smith with some help from jonathan vr
bounces back from 3-0 to strike him out
and keep the mets in the lead jd davis
match with two men out of the seventh
with one out
jd flies this one deep to right back
goes joyce to a warning track takes a
look and it's out of here
jd davis with an opposite field
three-run homer on the first pitch
thrown by josh smith and there's the big
hit the men's need it's now eight to
four new york in the seventh
one-man wrecking crew tonight jd davis
again using
the opposite field
bottom of the eighth and the marlins
debut of pat vin diddy he is an
ambidextrous pitcher and here comes the
switch hitter right now billy hamilton
due to hit the pitcher must declare
which hand he's pitching with
hamilton's been about right-handed
vendetti at the moment is set up to
pitch left-handed here he's got the the
six finger glove in there too so it's
got webbing essentially on both sides
soft liner and oh john bernie goes up
and makes the catch
back to back nights where a marlins
second baseman skies to make a play
taking a hit away from billy hamilton
and ending the eighth inning marlons are
not going away quietly they've got two
out and two on and they need just one
more base runner to get the tying run of
the plate and corey dickerson coming up
again the 1-2
he struck him out and the ball game is
over david peterson gets a win in his
city field debut
and the mets even up the series with the
marlins